is there a time limit for someone's
dreams does someone create like a
business plan and they say hey I'm
coming to LA and I give myself x amount
of time to quote make it and if I don't
I'm out of here does someone give a time
limit like that you know I talked to
somebody about that one time in and hour
maybe it was a podcast and I remember he
kind of all blurs together but they said
that if you give yourself an out that
you will eventually take it and so I'm
kind of making choices right now that
are burning other bridges and we talked
about earlier so I'd have no choice but
to continue this dream and figure it out
and make it happen interesting so do you
think when people maybe come from a
family where they say hey it's great
that you're an actor filmmaker but you
know what why don't you get this
economics degree too just in case this
whole thing doesn't work out so do you
think that's setting something up for
failure or you think that's being
realistic so that they won't end up you
know not in the financial position they
want to be in years down the line yeah I
mean that's I think that it is
unrealistic to want to succeed in
Hollywood it's just there's so much
competition yeah but I don't I can't I
can't really do anything else sure it's
a drive no one's can't quit I'm sorry
yeah we've talked to other people too
that I'm said why can't I wife said like
I can either direct films or I'm a
really good busboy I can there's no you
know and and and some people get that
they totally get it but I'm just
wondering is there someone said any kind
of deadline or they just say hey you
know what it's been X amount of years
and I'm I'm going to be okay with the
fact that I'm still not where I want to
be but I'm still continuing to do what
want to do do you think that's more than
mindset we should all have or that we
should give ourselves this sort of tough
love approach I don't mean I I can't I
can't promote following your dreams
completely because it is so difficult it
takes a certain kind of person to even
be willing to basically sell most of
your life to get something and a lot of
people say if you're not giving a
hundred percent then you won't succeed
kevin Pollak on his talk show says that
all the time I don't at the same time
you know a lot of my friends have what I
would call not not lived up to their
dreams and they're pretty happy just
that's I can't do that and this maybe
there's something broken or maybe
there's something more holy myself but I
just can't do that and it's not I've
tried I've tried I want to do another
more stable work it just and it's not
that it's not that I would be a great
busboy I mean I have other careers that
I have had the opportunity to follow it
just
it's so empty to me the fullness that my
friends have doing those other things I
just don't have it look what I'm not
creating am a depressed unpleasant
person to be around my wife can attest
to that when I'm when I'm making movies
when I'm writing I'm happier so I don't
know any other way to be I think it's
great that you know that about yourself
though I think there's people that don't
know that about themselves they think
that hey okay hey I've got this thing
i'm going to this job and i'm here i'm
set on this path but they don't realize
why maybe they're not fulfilled or maybe
they're busy gossiping about other
people when it's really that they should
be focusing on their own passions
instead of worrying about what other
people are doing and I think it's great
that you're that you know that about
yourself you know I mean not everybody
does I know Julia camera talked about
being a blocked creative you know and
what that does to people it's
interesting too because we've heard a
lot of people who have sort of
quote-unquote made it they've been very
very close to losing everything they've
put a ton of money on a credit card
they've slept in their car sure are you
willing to take big risks like that
because that's scary and that could
really affect the rest of your life it
could affect your family's life are you
willing to do big risks like that or I
think I think that there are ways of
doing things that don't necessarily
involve those kind of risks I made a
movie for two thousand dollars I didn't
need to leverage my my my future to do
that I just waited and I got a job and I
made the money that's why I'm making
funding my current film you know I took
side gigs and freelance jobs and made it
do you have to I don't I don't think
it's necessary to think you can do you
can do both reasonably I'm not going to
risk my wife my wife is more important
to me than my film career
so I'm not going to risk her or her
future to do this or my relationship
with her but at the same time it is my
life and it drives me so I mean I there
I think I think as a person you have to
set up I will go this far and no further
otherwise what kind of person will you
be what we will you kill somebody to
make a movie and I'm not using that as a
metaphor what you actually murder
someone to make a movie like the Tim
Robbins movie about making films all
right or will you you know how far will
you go to do it and then what kind of
person are you at the other end if
you're willing to make those compromises
the player yeah yeah yeah so
you gotta follow it but there's got to
be limits to and maybe that's what
you're talking about earlier with with
with you know I give myself ten years or
whatever to succeed I don't know but I
can't stop and I can't sacrifice my wife
so I got a fine balance